I was a real man I watched the Bengals
played the Buffalo Bills
how do you say it Bengals Bengals no you
say Bengals Bengals yeah I'm just saying
you're saying like the rock group The
Bangles yeah watch the Bangles like
these girls got out there played yeah
you know what Robin here's the problem
with you I'm trying to be masculine and
now you're you're feminizing me I want
to say Bangles
[Laughter]
the Cincinnati Bengals I I don't know
what Robin is trying to do that's how
you say Bengals Cincinnati Bengals
that's how you say it it's Bengals
say it Richard Richard said Richard
you're sick status shut up say it say
the Cincinnati Bengals
Bingo Bangles bingos
Bengals is what Susanna Hoffs was in
you're saying Bengals Bengals you're
saying something totally cool it's like
Bingo when he says it like Bing Crosby
bingos
what do you have covid no I uh I went
out I went out this weekend for the
first time in a very very very long time
to the Eagles game and I'm feeling it
the official pronunciation is Robin's
right Ben gals like Ben Stern Ben Giles
Bengals so from now on everyone will say
the Cincinnati Bengals I watched It's
driving JD crazy that they're the
Bengals now no the bad guys are actually
the cheerleaders that's the name of
their cheerleading oh is that right yes
well I tuned in the game
and I said why I wrote Raph I said why
am I rooting for the Bengals
I said I guess I said because of JD I
guess you know I I know it makes JD
happy and I'm like picturing him rocking
back and forth watching the game ass so
I thought gee this is kind of fun I'm
being masculine I'll text JD
and I'll tell him I'm watching the game
and then I said you know what's gonna
happen I'm going to text him I'm
watching the game and that I'm rooting
for the Bengals and he's gonna go you
jinxed it you jinxed the game yeah this
is why they lost or something some
[__] like that and I went you know
what [__] it I'm not gonna bother the
guy I think the exact same thing when I
think about texting him during games I'm
like he's gonna get pissed if something
goes the wrong way and blame me uh well
I wouldn't uh I I wouldn't I think I'd
be okay I might not respond to you
immediately I might wait a little bit to
see what happens
first of all I'm your boss you respond
immediately you're going to [__] around
with that
wait I'm not gonna I'm not gonna respond
to you
if you don't but if you don't like me I
don't eat but who cares it's my bengalo
I gotta see if you're a jinx
I gotta put my toe in the water and see
if you're in Jake's
foreign